beginning next year two more States will
allow the legal sale of marijuana for
recreational use voters in Maryland and
Missouri gave the green light to legal
pot in November's election they'll join
19 other states in Washington D.C in
which marijuana can be purchased for
recreational use according to 2020
Census Data more than 158 million
Americans now have access to Legal pots
in their home state despite that the
illegal marijuana trade is still
flourishing even in a state like
California where pot's been legal for
six years John Blackstone shows us the
cost of these illegal operations
in what can look like a military
operation enforcement officers of the
California Department of Fish and
Wildlife make their way through dense
brush of the Santa Rosa Plateau
ecological preserve
in densely populated Southern California
this nearly 9 000 acre Wildland has
largely set aside for wildlife
but it's also proved to be a popular
place for illegal marijuana growing this
is probably several thousand plant grow
that was harvested Lieutenant Lyle Chan
heads the fish and wildlife team that's
come in to clean up the mess Left Behind
after Growers have been captured or fled
is this typical of what you find this is
pretty typical this looks like a layup
spot or sleeping quarters so you can
tell by there's there's a cot here and a
cot over there so at least two
individuals were living here at one time
this site went undiscovered for at least
a year much of it hidden under the trees
with camouflage tops so we'll Harvest it
on site dry the cannabis plant and then
they'll trim the flower off and package
it into one pound bags ready to go full
operation full operations start to
finish it is exactly the kind of illegal
growing that was widely expected to
disappear when California voted to make
marijuana legal back in 2016. the idea
was that you Legalize It and that'll
drive out the illegal industry Daniel
Sumner is an agricultural Economist at
the University of California Davis are
there regulations in California working
I would say nobody thinks they're
working Sumner is co-author of a book
subtitled the blunt realities of
cannabis economics and the reality is
illegal growing still makes economic
sense they're making money they are
selling it without taxes without
regulations and often illegal sellers
have a long established customer base
and now they're told go down to the mall
buy it from somebody you don't know
because it's government approved and why
should I do that and the government said
oh so you can pay twice as much
you know so the average traditional
buyer of weed said no thank you if
putting the illegal Growers out of
business means closing that gap between
legal and illegal price are there states
that have done a much better job of
lowering that Gap there are a number of
states Washington Oregon Colorado have
lower retail prices than California like
everything else the customer is always
right and here the customer is a user of
weed and they will turn to the legal
weed when it's cheaper for them so I
would say focus on that retail price do
what you can in terms of regulations
keeping a sound system I'm not saying no
regulations but but doing what you can
to reduce that retail price Gap that's
really key
back in the Santa Rosa Plateau the cost
of illegal growing can also be measured
by the Damage Done to the environment
it's heartbreaking and it's frustrating
to know that we have spent so much time
and money
trying to protect this land Jennifer
Nguyen is an environmental manager with
California Fish and Wildlife you know at
the heart of our mission is to protect
California's plants and animals and this
comes as no surprise it's been happening
quite regularly
but it's frustrating
the first step in making things right is
trying to pick up everything left behind
by The Growers
snack food to drip irrigation systems
not only do they use the land they steal
the water yes you see all the poly pipe
that are illegally here on the
psychological reserve it takes water
from the plants and animals that need it
to survive
all the trash is bundled up ready to be
lifted Away by helicopter but other
scars are left behind well you see they
have to move the land and they have to
make flat spots to put the plants and to
irrigate now the hillside is very loose
soil when the rains come it washes all
the debris the sediment the dirt and all
of the fertilizers and any toxic
pesticides that they use right into the
waterways and continues on the debris is
gone but it may be years before the land
has healed for CBS Saturday morning John
Blackstone the Santa Rosa plateau
he makes a great point I mean if if it
costs that much more to buy it legally
at a store with the regulations and
everything else then people just look to
buy anything exactly what I didn't think
about was that environmental tool oh
absolutely and stealing the water that
was probably the biggest thing obviously
you think about that footprint left
behind but stealing the water from those
other resources that need it and then
the time it takes for them to sort of
live on the land like that it's tough
but
like going on there